about the rules of when you're up
material why is it good to trade pieces
and when you're down material why is it
good to trade pond so first of all I'm
going to ask you guys about that the
main question is when you're down
material why do you want to trade ponds
if you're up material the more pieces
you trade the more your material
advantage is going to become apparent a
one-point advantage in a King and pawn
endgame is huge right so that's what
you're kind of just aiming for you know
that a one-point advantage when they're
very few pieces left on the board just
like Kings is basically winning so
you're quite ready to just trade off as
much as possible to get to that but when
let's say you're down upon right um
yes the more pawns you get off the board
the more likely it is that you can reach
some theoretically drawn end games like
let's say at some point you're down a
pawn or even two and you can let's say
you have a situation your opponent has a
rook a knight and two extra pawns right
and you have a rook in a knight so you
managed to trade down everything and all
you've got is your work in your knight
you still at your opponent as two pawns
but let's say you can sacrifice your
remaining Knight right for those two
pawns you get all those pawns off the
board and he's left with a rook and a
knight against your rook well
unfortunately for him that's draw right
so yes he's got that piece advantage but
because there are no pawns left on the
board you know you've swam your way to
to a theoretically drawn position or
maybe your opponent has a you know a
pawn or two extra and in some kind of
Bishop Ben's game but you've managed
trade off so many pawns and somewhere
you you notice the opportunity to give
up your bishop for a couple of the pawns
they're left and you leave him in a
position where he's only a bishop it's
not enough winning material right and
all of these things are possible because
you've gotten all the
Ahn's off the board so there that's why
it's a good strategy the more pawns you
get off the board the more those ideas
of sacrificing some peace for the
remaining pawns to get into a position
where maybe your opponent has only an
extra bishop or an extra night or maybe
it's rook and Knight versus rook or even
rook and Bishop versus rook could be
defensible you know I mean it's hard to
defend but it is you know defensible
that I mean that's that's the idea
you're trying to reach some piece
endgame or maybe your opponent has a
bishop at night and you have a night
where you have a bishop you know that
one piece advantage of his it's not
going to help him when there are no
pawns on the board let's um I'm going to
have a question for you guys the guys
are good at calculation now I know
you're gonna say no but but we're going
to give you a couple it's not very
difficult but it's both a mixture of a
little bit of calculation and some
knowledge this is from my last round a
game in a tournament I was playing in in
Baku so I needed a draw for my
grandmaster norm and I was white now
obviously white doesn't want to draw in
this position anymore right whites I
mean I'm up a rook so the trick here is
not to blunder and sift some kind of
checkmate you know because of course the
King is a little bit weak and you want
to be careful um
there's always Queen h4 ideas right okay
so I played Bishop h3 here your job is
to figure out what I was thinking why am
i blundering my bishop or giving it away
for free
what's the what's the catch
so all the people who saw this in my
article don't need to answer this
question I will have other questions for
them okay yes I'm looking for my
wonderful database where you did solve
it in the article it was cute right I
mean I haven't like I have to say like
when I played this move Bishop h3 you
know my friend Emile you know he was
watching the game and you know I made
eye contact with him and you know I
could tell he was put you he was pleased
when he saw the idea because it's not
like absolutely obvious you know it or
like a bystander you know but when he's
again it's obviously a surprising move
because you know white does not have to
give up their Bishop you know there are
lots of other moves and so when you see
this move looks so unusual and then when
you see the idea it's kind of like oh
wow you know that's kind of nice um so I
could tell that he appreciated it um
when I played it and it basically ended
on that's true you're up a lot of
material and you trade a lot you can
basically give away everything to get
something very basic that you know is
winning to provide you guys on the side
of the room that that don't read my
articles yes
and
all right very good so the thing is I'm
giving up like all my extra material
just to navigate my way to a King and
pawn endgame that I know is going to be
winning so first we take Black has no
real choice unless they want to be down
a rook with no compensation and this
Queen trade is the point if I didn't
have the move Queen Ji Won this would
all be like completely pointless I would
never you know give up my bishop and
then my rook for this so the point is
that I force this Queen trade and
because I have an outside past pawn I
win the game so all you know based on
this concept of the outside past pawn
which um you know do you guys have a lot
of experience with that do you ever see
it come up in your games because I find
like it's very relevant actually a lot
of people totally underestimate it
mm-hmm right mm-hmm
so you know of course white King comes
up and takes this pawn and the b-pawn
decides the game so and if black did not
take the bishop well one of the points
of this move is that actually I just
want to take the pawn and deflect the
Queen from the e3 Bishop and then just
you know it was a nice pawn to take my
opponent was kind of out of moves here
since there are no checks or anything
useful that he can do and he played f5
to try to guard the g4 pawn but that had
the problem of leaving his King
unguarded and suddenly the Queen comes
in with check and for example I just
have to make sure not to give that check
right and so but this check is good
enough and I win the bishop and then
there are no more checks and the whites
up a lot of material so he resigned
after this one so I was pleased you know
what this kind of um it was like
aesthetic and aesthetically pleasing
solution to try to take your material
advantages just off minimalize it to get
into winning King and pawn endgame it is
black to move in this position guys um
tell me
what kind of move you would make here
for black and whether you like the move
Knight f5 in particular to get what
result right well to do what to answer
the question of whether native five is a
good move so what do you think well then
I mean well at least pick one of those
methods to come up with an answer yeah
you know whether it's calculation or
strategy you think it's the one who move
you want to avoid why do you think is
something you want to avoid what's the
general idea that makes you think say
you say that alright so you've got a
pair so you've got to count how it works
out is it I mean obviously white was a
maybe White's a little bit control
concerns you know what the way white can
lose this position of course this pawn
is so advanced if they ever lose this
pawn they're going to lose the game
right so there is you know something for
them they get to be worried about if
they do absolutely you know they play
absolutely terribly then there are
chances for them to lose this game and
maybe they were probably concerned after
king of six that the king is not going
anywhere like king e4 right and their
king is not it's kind of stuck and if
their Knight moves then King d5 is
possible so you know in a rapid game you
can all obviously you know a lot
hallucinating actually I think the best
move would have been this move and this
kind of works tactically because you're
not letting the King come in right away
because it loses the bishop so you've
got to sort of notice that otherwise you
don't want to play 95 it only looks like
it just helps
the king advanced right if your idea was
like to go here then you know you can
see why block would still be a little
bit concerned here you know the bishop
and the King they seem stronger than
this Knights and I guess the king could
still come here but you know blocks a
little bit worried the knight is quite a
not very good at fighting side pawns
right and this pawn is very far advanced
so I can see why um
block was a little bit concerned here
and kind of immediately went for this
sort of you know try to get this counter
play against the h4 pawn so block was
definitely not in the mood to win this
game right because if you play Knight f5
you're obviously not trying to win right
but you're trying to draw now the
question is are you drawing or not let's
do the counts guys because that's very
important is you know what King and pawn
end games is one thing we have to be
very precise it's not general principles
are helpful right but you also want to
be able to see exactly move by move
what's happening if you get one move
wrong you know the game just you know
runs away from you so let's get a little
bit of practice with that
right so unfortunately for black the
transition to a King and pawn endgame
was the chose a bad time to do it yes
because this King gets more active than
blacks King it goes here you can stop
him from going to the Queen side for now
and this position would be nice if it
weren't for these this pawn right at
this point you can make it disappear
you'd be making a draw here right but
the problem is white uses their reserve
tempo to break the opposition and
whichever way black goes they go the
opposite way and they win the King and
pawn endgame right so this in this um
kind of I mean it's a very sad mistake
by black but one of the things on I
think it's very important for sort of
you know beginner and intermediate
players to UM realize is how careful
they need to be with transitions you
know from any type of endgame to a King
and pawn endgame so you guys know about
this right how no how do you know just
because that one decision can cost you
the game the kingdom pawn endgame can be
evaluated very precisely if you get it
wrong you lose if you make a mistake in
an endgame with a minor piece or rooks
on the board you have a lot more leeway
right so when you're when you play
Knight f5 and you realize like your
opponent can actually go into pure King
and pawn endgame you have to have very
good idea of what's going to happen
there so you don't want to be making
that type of mistake mm-hmm it's a rapid
game this is the end of a rapid game so
you know I'm sure players have you know
30 seconds or less but still even um
again it's a matter obviously black
miscounted because I'm sure black knows
all these principles but but for you
guys the lesson to take away is main
thing is just to be very careful at
those moments because you'd rather take
your chances you know make this move or
something take your chances in this type
of position you know it's it's more
likely that if you make a second rate
move that does not drastically change
the nature of the position then you know
your game is not going to be lost
just on that decision so be very careful
about the decisions that take the game
into pure King and pawn endgame for
example there's a very famous position
let me try to recall it come it is white
to move here white to move and it's up
to you to figure out what is going on
here you know I was sharp little
position but where there's definitely
you know they're forcing moves
yes
Queen f7 well my move is forced well
mine was forced okay
and how do you evaluate this position
and
right do you guys agree with that I mean
do you think that how do you think white
is winning here
can you tell already not sure yet she's
gonna win why you can go to for Flossie
on two on one on the queenside you break
that open King goes over there blacks
King then you go to the King side so
you're going to so let's say we play
here and you play here and I play here
and you play here and I play here how
are you going to go around go about
winning this well I think right now I
need either degrade and see or I mean
even wherever the King goes you're gonna
to a move do you want to make a go
beaver was hoping you would do that okay
um you might still win but I was hoping
you would make this move because it's
actually such an instructive mistake
yes exactly yeah no really it is it's
people get this wrong all the time and
it's so sad they have this winning
position and then they push the wrong
pawn you always you know if it's a
matter of technique you always want to
push the pawn that you know has nothing
in front of it because one of the worst
things that can happen to you in a King
and pawn endgame is when your pawn
majority gets fixed by you know a lesser
amount of pawns and all of a sudden it's
like hey well I used to have mobile
pawns that could become a passed pawn
now my pawns are held by one pawn and
I'm facing this this you know past pawn
in this particular position I think you
could maybe survive this to win because
you got immediately actually first thing
maybe you want to do is you can even
start with this move your king is in a
good enough position that you can sort
of afford to do this give it up and come
back for it and things have not been
altered too badly for white White's
going to win this pawn it doesn't really
matter the King activity like sure you
let this can get a bit more active but I
think what was still essentially from
well why this is essentially going to be
okay for what is the fact that they have
an outside path pawn right such a huge
huge advantage in King and pawn end
games who has the outside pass pawn I
mean we can check to see is this enough
to win Kings III you know are we going
to win this let's say king c5 king here
let's say King here if I go this way you
go here I go here you go here and take I
would think you win is your king close
enough to the pawns I think so but we
need to check I can run away from you
but you attack me
yeah I think white king is close enough
that he are just close enough you know
that he can he can win this position by
King was a little bit be pawns very far
obviously from the King side aweso black
wins um but I'm since since it's
unlikely that you were you know
calculating this is this you know that's
why you got to be carefully and so you
don't run into things like that we have
to look for only moves like you know c3
or like king d3 your King might very
well not be in a position close enough
to the pond to still free it up right so
that's why the way you want to move your
pawns and that way they can advance
self-sufficiently is you always push the
pawn that has nothing in front of it
that way there's no danger to it being
fixed by your opponent's 1 pawn if you
just start a little bit slower right so
we're a little bit um you know we're not
doing it be three c4 but we're doing you
know c3 our opponents can't do anything
then B 3 and then c4 so just be careful
about how you advance your pawns because
one of those things traps you don't want
to fall into is getting your pawns pawn
majority fixed in a king and pawn and
the game alright so since we have some
advanced players here I'm going to show
you guys a couple of games very quickly
we're going to just start off that
contains some very important ideas
this is not not an endgame lesson but
it's more like a lesson in psychology so
I'm going to try to share this based on
two examples and this was part of a
lesson of a lecture that I prepared on
the theme of the initiative I had like
lots of examples but we're going to
distill it into two examples you know
ideally you don't put yourself into any
camp right you try to be versatile so
just as much you know you might be
inclined to play one style rather than
another but to you know really become a
good player you have to be versatile and
you know someone who is actually a very
good example of this is a is kramnik so
you guys you know we have a lot of
people here who've been playing for a
long time so you probably remember you
know the kramnik of like you know 1998
or 2000 when he played Kasparov in the
match right everyone thought I mean if
there was kramnik and there was Caspar
these two players with opposing styles I
mean you knew Katherine was like the
active player the UM guy who was very
good with the initiative and Kramnik
obviously didn't get into any
confrontations with him in their match
of that of that nature you know he
really tried to keep it technical when
some better ends games
um defends the berlin wall and so on and
so Kramnik you know was kind of
associated with that style for a long
time like more of a technical player
right but if you look at his games now
and over the last couple of years it's
just amazing because you know I think
more than any modern player in his games
you can really see on the fight for the
initiative and he often sacrifices
material and you know even like unsound
ways and win some brilliant games you
know his games are a lot of fun to look
at you know he he plays more like tall
now well you know definitely more than
he used to you know um but definitely a
lot of his games reminds you of tall you
know the computer is not going to
approve all of his sacrifices and he
plays them and he wins right that's like
an example of someone who's really
evolved with his style
Dubey what was considered that did be is
opening correct me if I'm wrong but
Sicilian be three right yeah I mean okay
now he even plays openings like that you
know you know the be three Sicilian I
mean in that particular game I think
you're talking about against in our key
of a really nice game that one he
actually won a very nice endgame and so
he did use his like positional
understanding and endgame skills and
that but um but it's true I mean it kind
of exemplifies the types of positions
he's going for he was obviously trying
to just get some kind of game from the
opening that's also probably an
influence of Carlsen um you know the way
Carlsen had he's been showing you know
in the last few years is that you know
you can just get a position from the
opening and you play and you try to win
your games that way so people have been
moving away I think from a lot of
theoretical stuff but basically you know
I mean um that's the reason that kramnik
even though he's like thirty eight years
old right he's really like at the top of
his game now like you can't really say
crammed Lee plays worse now than he did
eight years ago even though you would
think okay he's getting older you know
the minds not getting more powerful but
actually because he's evolving and his
stuff and he's changed his style he's
made that effort you know he's really
playing great chests these days so
people have to strive to be universal
okay this is an example actually from a
game of my coach um there was a rapid
game played this spring and he was white
and obviously I think it's you know it's
obvious to everyone here that white is
better right kind of a disastrous
position for black I mean he's sort of
holding on on this f6 square there's a
lot of pressure on that square very
passive I mean the King has had to go
over here because the King side was not
safe to Castle to but still you know how
do we break through the position is
rather lockdown
it looks like f6 is securely protected
by two minor pieces and the Queen you
know we don't have this square we know
we don't have this square or here
the bishop seems not to be doing very
much so it's still a question of how we
actually make progress so white found a
very unusual solution first thing he did
is he took that night now that doesn't
look like a good positional decision
doesn't you like it like if he played it
oh well you want to suck so you're
giving up your bishop with the idea
sacking your Queen for these two minor
pieces you'd play that in a game you're
not you're not afraid of giving up your
Queen just for two pieces I mean you
know the two pieces are a little bit
weaker what do you guys think would you
ever consider giving up your queen for
just these two pieces just to get your
rook to f6 and we'll take a look at that
idea guys does it have any merits
okay well you have suggested very
interesting idea this is what happened
white sacked the Queen to get no this is
this is my coach this little echo is
it's a real game it took place this uh
spring you know he's not at all like
player actually I mean he's a more of a
I would say more like of a Kramnik
player you know still different from
tall he's a very good positional
understanding but he also has an
appreciation for the initiative and
you're going to see this these two
examples are from his games so Rick f6o
right
we've sax our Queen for two pieces and
this queen is attacked this pawn is
attacked and Queen has to retreat right
Queenie seven runs into you know d6 and
this doesn't you know we win the Queen
back we have two pieces for the rook so
this didn't look so appealing it's a
queen of fate how does white follow up
here now that's interesting
rook c6 King b7 mm-hmm yes your works
are getting very active on the sixth
rank I need to guard the square don't I
I mean I don't really want to let you do
that so what if I play here I want to
find control the b6 square well you
don't want to do that because I'm going
to give up my queen for both of your
rooks right and I'll work d6 mm-hmm this
rook right ah the strong oh I think I
ran into a problem here Oh kind of wait
I might get lucky oh maybe I have the
square I'm kind of on my last you know
legs here because you mean obviously you
want to make that move right I'm almost
getting mated
yeah you can't uh couldn't take the rook
unfortunately I don't think you can do
this because I don't think anything any
discovered attacks you have here are
that dangerous rook c7 right this one Oh
rookie 7 you want to play on okay thank
you for explaining that yes you're very
tricky unfortunately this is not mate
because Knights move backwards yes look
at that defender gosh oh I do I do I'm
going to bring all my remaining my
strong pieces back kind of funny how
black is like you know squirming here
with his Queen and rooks and only
against these pieces but I mean it's
obviously it's not so easy to win you
know when you're down that much material
but that's interesting yeah yes your Mac
well so what happened is black white
actually played this move so he um added
the D pawn into the game and the night
right so he did maximize his pieces and
the pawn can go to d7 with your idea of
plan a sixth-ranked so you know you're
actually going to carry out that idea
but you've got a lot more you know to
support it now is kind of a key moment
ah what should black play I'll show you
the game and then you'll see maybe you
can we'll come back to this moment black
played rugby eight yeah he's attacking
this pawn white pushes it forward now he
probably should have played King a seven
kind of a prophylaxis against rugby six
new black is not feeling so happy here
um but instead he played this move
what did a white play here guys
exactly he made a very nice move you
know normally when you're faced with a
check from a queen you want to move your
king to safety right um but this move at
least allows black's queen to get active
and this actually starts to resemble a
powerful piece yeah the king is you know
definitely maximized on d1
and it's just very funny how these
pieces you know dominate the queen that
she has no infiltration squares although
she's got that active diagonal yes it's
actually um white black resigned here oh
I think he could have made a few more
moves you know of course he was quite
disgusted or I think with this position
the big threat is a rugby six and rook F
to F 6 and then we're just going to meet
them on the 6th rank yes so a nice
example of domination by white um he was
an IM ok question here so what black did
obviously was not so didn't put up a lot
of resistance is there anything he could
have done better
I mean cuz after all he does have a
queen it's not like he needs to resign
yet think about what White's next move
is going to be
what's White's next move going to be d7
right d7 rugby six if you don't activate
any of your pieces which is what black
didn't manage to do in this game you're
going to lose can you do something to
activate your pieces can you mean can
you try who can you try to activate well
not this rook right he tried to activate
this rook or something but it turns out
his route very his move is very routine
right okay he attacked the pawn
obviously white didn't give it up and
the rook didn't wind up doing all that
much there hey five is interesting
actually someone um in my previous
lecture on this theme suggested this
move yes with the idea of going Brook a
six this is definitely interesting
d7 rook a six yeah here there were some
interesting ideas involving the move um
yeah I believe this was it actually rook
f7 with the idea that if you take I take
right ah by Bishop covers f1 so if you
take me I can take also with the Queen
and keep the attack going I don't know I
mean of course I can make a knight but
yeah like I mean I think this is mate
you know I think mate is coming you know
so I kind of like taking with the Queen
um and if you go here what's funny is
you know I have this move and this is
kind of the unbelievable part um because
now even a rook has been traded so white
has even less attacking material than
before um you would think blocks should
be able to survive this my only threat
though is rook Yeats so we just kind of
stumbled on this line in analysis I want
to play rook e8 you know force out your
Queen and Queen myself right so you can
be like oh well maybe rook at eight but
the Queen is trapped so it's not a funny
construct like you can I mean the Queen
is not you know not a piece that is
easily trapped like that but it has
nowhere to go
yeah I mean it's it's just later
something we found in analysis you know
I don't know how hundreds inaccurate it
is but it seems like it makes some sense
in this position actually the Queen just
has nowhere to go and you can have both
simultaneously guard d8 and you know try
to save the queen like you can either do
one or the other actually this move I'm
thinking is uh I do that and you do that
and because you have a threat of meat
Wow
but now I can make a knight and I have a
feeling like if we have a lot of pieces
there I mean we should be able to do
something although I don't know your
your book cover is the sixth ring has to
be right I mean I almost attempted to
make this move to I wish I could make
this move but then you have you have a
couple of different ways of trying to
stop me from queening right and then
what and then rookie seven right and
then King b 8 and then rugby 7 King a 8
and Knight c7 you have to give up your
Queen yes yeah the night seems like it
wins you're right we just calculate that
a little bit so you know that's just one
line kind of shows that maybe a five and
rook a six is an interesting idea for
black but you know white seems to have a
lot of tactical resources there also